Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time, we were discussing
the rationality of suicide.
We separated the question of
the rationality of suicide from
the ethics of suicide or the
morality of suicide.
We'll be turning to the
morality of suicide later today.
But the first question in
thinking about the rationality
of suicide was whether or not it
could actually be the case that
somebody would be better off
dead.
Having argued that,
at least on what struck me as
the more plausible theory is,
that was a possibility,
we then turned to the question
of under what circumstances,
more particularly--or perhaps
the better way to put it,
at what point--would it be true
that suicide might be rational?"
In tackling the question,
we were initially bracketing
the question about whether you
could ever reasonably or
rationally judge that the
circumstances actually obtained.
We'll turn to that question in
a few minutes.
The question we were focusing
on originally was just,
from the objective perspective,
as it were, what does the graph
need to look like in order for
it to be the case that you'd be
better off dead and suicide
would be a rational choice?
I drew a variety of different
graphs, different lines about
your life doing better or worse,
and noted for each one of them,
at what point,
if ever, suicide might be a
reasonable choice.
I want to draw a couple of more
graphs before ending this bit of
the discussion.
You'll recall the axes.
The x axis represents time.
The y axis represents how good
or bad your life is overall,
taking into account the value
of being alive,
per se, if you accept a
valuable container theory.
The higher the line,
the better your life is at that
time.
The lower the line,
the worse your life is at that
time.
You might say,
the easy cases,
at least in the philosophical
point of view,
are ones where things get
worse.
Eventually, your life becomes
worse than nothing.
You'd be better off dead.
And it's going to stay that way
until such time as you might die
from natural causes.
Dying from natural causes.
In a situation like this,
killing yourself from here on
out would make sense,
assuming you knew the facts,
could trust your judgment,
and so forth and so on.
Some of the issues that we'll
come back to in a minute.
And indeed, as we saw,
there will be even cases in
which it might make sense to
kill yourself earlier,
if this was the last chance at
which you had the ability to
kill yourself or not,
even though you'd be giving up
some life that was worth living,
that was the only way to avoid
a much larger chunk of life that
was not worth living.
So, suicide might still make
sense.
On the other hand,
if the choice was way back
here, although this is--killing
yourself early on would be the
only way to avoid the later
chunk not worth living,
at least if that chunk's small
enough--suppose it was like
this--you'd say it doesn't make
sense to kill yourself this
early.
You'd be throwing away too
much, even though that's the
only way to avoid the bad stuff.
Now, as I say,
that's the easy graph,
where you go from a life worth
living to a life not worth
living and it stays there.
But suppose instead,
we have a situation like this.
Here, life becomes worse than
nothing for a while,
but you recover.
You're going to return to a
life that's worth having.
And suppose that after you
recover, you'll have a very nice
third stage, third act of your
life before you would eventually
die of natural causes or natural
death.
Here, the crucial point to
make, of course,
is that even though for a while
your life will be worse than
nothing,
negative overall,
it doesn't mean that it makes
sense to kill yourself at this
point.
Because, of course,
although it's true that if you
do kill yourself here,
you're avoiding this negative
chunk,
this bit below the x axis,
doing that also throws away the
very large third act where your
life returns to being better
than nothing.
Since the choices have neither
of these, or both,
and the positive third act is
great enough to outweigh the
negative second act,
on balance, it doesn't make
sense.
But of course--,
So even though your life might
be worse than nothing for some
stretch, suicide wouldn't
necessarily be a rational
decision.
But it's crucial in making that
argument, that the--what I've
been calling the third act.
Here's act one,
here's act two,
here's act three.
It's crucial in making this
argument is that the third act
was sufficiently great,
sufficiently long and
sufficiently high that it
outweighs the bad of the second
act.
And although that's true the
way I've drawn the graph,
we could imagine that it wasn't
quite like that.
Suppose that after the second
act, in which your life is not
worth living,
you will recover and have a
third act in which life once
again is good for you,
overall.
Still at this point,
act three doesn't outweigh act
two.
Although there's a recovery,
it's too short and not high
enough to outweigh the bad of
act two.
And so, under that
circumstance,
when you ask yourself,
let's say at this moment,
would suicide here be rational?
the answer could well be "yes."
Although in killing yourself
you've given up act three,
which would be good for you
overall,
doing that's the only way to
avoid act two,
which is bad for you overall,
and sufficiently bad to
outweigh the good of act three.
So, if you've got the choice of
suicide here,
it might well be rational.
Notice however,
that the crucial point,
again, is when are we
talking about the possibility of
committing suicide?
Committing suicide here might
be rational, but not
necessarily, indeed not at all,
at this later moment.
Because at this point,
the fact that you've gone
through act two is now history.
There's nothing you can do
about it.
You've had this horrible period
of your life and now it's over.
Your question is not,
can you avoid act two?
It's too late for that.
You're simply asking yourself,
what do I think about act
three?
Should I avoid act three?
And that doesn't make sense.
We've stipulated that act three
is good for you overall.
So here, suicide no longer
makes sense, even though it
would have made sense over here.
The interesting point is that
these possibilities are not mere
theoretical possibilities,
but actually can happen.
There's a famous case of,
in the bioethics literature,
of somebody who suffered a
horrible set of burns over a
great deal of their body and had
to go through a period,
a very long period,
of recovery in which they were
hospitalized,
basically immobilized and in a
great deal of pain,
while their nerves regenerated
and their skin regrafted and the
like.
And early on in that period,
this person said,
although he believed that he'd
eventually recover,
what he was going to have to go
through was so horrible that he
wished he were dead.
Because of the nature of his
hospitalization,
he wasn't able to kill himself.
He asked that he be killed and
people refused.
He went through a period and
sure enough, he recovered.
And eventually, he said, "Yes.
Now my life is worth living
again.
And of course,
since it is worth living,
now that I'm able to kill
myself, it no longer makes sense
for me to kill myself.
Because here I am," as he might
put it, "in act three with a
life worth living.
But for all that,
even though I now have a life
worth living,
I haven't changed my opinion
that it would have been better
for me back here toward the
beginning of act two for me to
have been killed,
or for me to have died.
It remains the case that I wish
I had died here,
so as to avoid all the pain and
suffering,
even though I'm now in a period
which is better for me,
good for me overall."
All right. One other case.
This is just repeating a point
that actually I made very early
on.
In all of these cases where
I've argued for the rationality
of suicide, it's because
eventually the line has dipped
below the x axis.
The crucial point to remember
is, even if your situation
deteriorates and indeed doesn't
recover, that still doesn't make
suicide rational.
The question is not,
am I worse off than I had been
or than I might have been had I
not had the decline?
The question in thinking about
the rationality of suicide is,
am I so badly off that I'm
better off dead?
And if your life is a
sufficiently rich and valuable
one, there's a great deal of
room for going down,
having a worse life,
while still ending up at a life
better than nothing.
In that case,
of course, suicide's not
rational at all.
Still, it does seem to me that
there are cases in which the
line does cut below the x axis
and remains there for a
sufficiently long time,
perhaps remains there forever,
so that the person is better
off dead.
And so we might say,
from that point of view,
if only the person could
recognize the facts and know for
a certainty that's what their
line was going to look like,
suicide would at certain points
be rational.
Still, that means we need to
turn to the second part of the
question.
Somebody who believes suicide
cannot be rational might say,
look, the whole game is in the
phrase I just used.
Sure, there are situations in
which if only you knew the
facts, if only you had a crystal
ball and knew for a certainty
this is what my life is going to
go on from here on out,
then suicide would be rational.
But of course,
we never have a crystal ball.
We never have the guarantee
that this is how the line's
going to go.
So, the question we need to
turn to now is,
could it be rational for you to
judge that your situation is one
in which the line's going to go
below and stay below,
or stay below long enough,
so that on balance,
you'd be better off dead?
Let's suppose that somebody's
situation is like that,
or at least there can be
situations like that.
Could it ever be reasonable to
judge that your situation is
like that?
And if so, could it ever then
be reasonable to act on that
judgment and end your life?
We're still bracketing
questions about morality.
Here we're still looking at
things from the personal,
rational perspective.
And once again,
what I want to do next is
distinguish two questions.
I want to distinguish between
questions about what should we
say if you were thinking clearly
versus what should we say if
your thinking is clouded.
Again, one might think,
look, in the type of cases
where suicide might be
rationally warranted,
it's going to be so stressful,
that nobody can think clearly
in the middle of that situation.
And so even if it were true
that you could reasonably decide
to commit suicide if only you
were thinking clearly,
nobody does think clearly.
Let's come back to that worry
in a moment.
Let's assume for the moment
that you can think clearly about
your situation.
Perhaps you've got some sort of
painful disease,
but the disease is not painful
constantly.
There are periods in which it
comes to an end,
brief periods in which you're
able to assess your situation,
weigh up the facts.
Could it ever be rational in
that situation to decide to kill
yourself?
Well, as I say,
we don't have a crystal ball.
If you did have a crystal ball,
if you knew for a certainty
that your line was so bad that
it was below zero and wasn't
going to recover,
perhaps we'd say,
yeah, in that case,
it would be rational to commit
suicide.
But we don't have a crystal
ball.
What should we say then?
The critics of suicide might
come back and say,
well look, since you don't have
a crystal ball,
since you never know for sure
that you won't recover,
since there's always a
possibility of recovery,
suicide never makes sense.
After all, we all know that
there's constant progress in
medicine.
People are always making
breakthroughs and what seems
like an incurable disease one
day may have some sort of cure
the next.
But if you killed yourself,
you've thrown away any chance
of getting that cure.
And even if medical cures don't
come around, various diseases
sometimes simply have miraculous
remissions.
Somebody might just get better
spontaneously.
That's always a possibility.
It doesn't happen very often,
but it does happen now and
then.
And again, if you've killed
yourself, you've thrown away any
chance of recovery.
So the critics of suicide might
say, given that there's a
chance, however small,
of recovery,
whether through medical
progress or just some sort of
medical miracle--but of course,
if you kill yourself there's no
chance of recovery--given that,
it doesn't make any sense.
It can't make sense rationally
to kill yourself.
That sort of position gets
articulated now and again.
But I think it's got to be
mistaken.
It's true that we don't have a
crystal ball,
and so in deciding whether to
kill yourself,
what you're doing is playing
the odds.
You're gambling.
But still, gambling is
something we do all the time.
Indeed, there is no getting
away from the fact that in the
suicide case,
in the case of some terminally
ill patient,
or at least somebody who
appears to be terminally ill,
there is no getting away from
the fact that regardless of what
decision he or she makes,
they are gambling.
Gambling, playing the odds,
just is one of the facts of
life about how we have to
decide.
We have to make our decisions
under uncertainty.
Now, suppose somebody says
then, look, since we agree that
we're deciding under
uncertainty,
it doesn't make sense to throw
away the small chance of
recovery.
Then I want to say,
that doesn't seem to be in
keeping with the rules that we
would normally use in deciding
how to face a gamble.
At the back of this room there
are two doors.
So let's tell a little fantasy,
science fiction story about the
two doors.
After class is over,
you're going to have to decide
which one of these doors to go
through.
Let's suppose that if you go
through door one,
it's virtually guaranteed that
what will happen is you'll be
kidnapped and your kidnappers
will then torture you for a
week,
after which perhaps you'll be
released.
Virtually certain,
90% certain,
99% certain,
perhaps 99.9% certain.
There's a small chance,
1 in 1,000,1 in 10,000,
that you won't be kidnapped and
tortured.
Instead, you'll be whisked away
to a wonderful,
tropical vacation where you'll
have a fantastic time for a
week.
Not very likely,
but not impossible,
1 in 1,000;
1 in 10,000, maybe less.
That's if you go through door
one.
Door one has 99.99% chance of a
week of torture,
and a 0.01 or 0.001,
whatever it is,
percent chance of wonderful
vacation.
On the other hand,
if you go through door number
two, 100% certainty that the
following is going to happen.
You will immediately fall
asleep.
You'll be in a deep,
dreamless state for the week,
at which point you'll wake up.
Well, what should you do?
What should you pick?
It's not quite certainty of
being tortured versus certainty
of sleeping.
If it was certainty of being
tortured versus certainty of
sleeping, I suppose we'd all
agree the thing to do is to go
through door number two.
Sleep's nothing positive,
but on the other hand,
it's nothing negative.
I suppose if we were going to
slap a number on it,
we'd give it a zero.
But torture is clearly a
negative.
And if it's a week of torture,
it's a very large negative.
So, it's zero versus some huge
negative number.
Certainty versus certainty,
what should you pick?
We'd all agree,
I presume, you should pick door
number two and pick the
dreamless sleep for a week.
Now we remember,
but wait a minute,
it wasn't certain that
you were going to be tortured,
it was just very,
very, very likely that you were
going to be tortured.
And imagine if somebody says,
oh, you must go for the
gold.
Go for door number one.
Sure, it's overwhelming likely
that you're going to be
tortured.
But there's a very small chance
that you'll get this wonderful
vacation.
Whereas, if you pick door
number two, you're throwing that
chance away.
And so, the only rational
decision must be to pick door
number one, to hold out for that
chance,
no matter how small of getting
that fantastic vacation.
That's the only rational
decision.
If anybody were to say that,
I'd laugh at them.
I'd say look,
if you want to talk about,
well maybe there's room for
choice either way,
it depends how great the
vacation is, something like
that.
Yeah, there's maybe room for
talk.
But if you want to insist that
the only rational
decision must be to hold out for
the chance of a wonderful
vacation,
no matter how small the
odds--given that if you don't
get that wonderful vacation,
you're going to be tortured and
you could avoid all that by
picking the sleep option--if
somebody insisted in the face of
all that,
that the only rational decision
is to go through the door which
is likely to be torture and a
vanishingly small chance of
vacation,
I'd say they're just wrong.
That's not a rationally
required decision,
given the odds.
Yes, question?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Shelly Kagan:
Great.
So, the question was this.
The point was,
perhaps I'm cheating in making
the example this way,
because death of course,
isn't--of course,
what you're all supposed to be
lulled into thinking is that
death,
choosing death,
choosing suicide,
is sort of like choosing to be
asleep, a state of dreamless
sleep,
but sleep nonetheless.
And the suggestion then was I'm
cheating, because death is
forever.
I deliberately framed the
example in terms of being
tortured for a week versus being
asleep for a week.
And perhaps given that choice,
it's clearly rationally
acceptable to decide that you'd
rather pick the sleep for a week
option.
But death isn't just for a week.
If you commit suicide,
you're dead forever.
So, let's change the example.
Suppose that--you guys are
mostly, I suppose,
in the vicinity of 20--s,uppose
that if you go through door
number one,
there's an overwhelmingly
likely chance,
90%, 99%, 99.9% chance that
you'll be kidnapped and
tortured.
And the torture will take place
and last for another 50,60,
70 years and then you die.
There's a slight chance,
a 10^(th) of a percent,
a 100^(th) of a percent that
no,
no, you won't be tortured for
the 50,60, 70 years,
but instead,
you'll be brought to this
tropical island paradise where
you'll have this great time for
the next 50 years.
But what has happened in 99 out
of 100 cases,
or 999 out of 1,000 cases,
or 9,999 out of 10,000 cases,
is the torture scenario.
While the people are being
tortured, they beg for mercy.
They beg to be put to death.
The wish they were dead.
It is truly the case that the
tortures are so bad that these
people are better off dead.
Remember, we're assuming that
you've got a case where you
really will be better off dead
unless the miraculous recovery
takes place.
And so again,
we have to ask,
in a situation like that where
the person says--And similarly
of course,
if you go through door number
two, you immediately fall
asleep, and you stay that way
for the next 70 years,
and then you die while in your
coma.
The fan of door number one
comes along and says the only
rational decision is to pick
door number one,
where it's overwhelmingly
likely that you face 50 years or
60 years or 70 years of torture.
Because, of course,
if you were to pick door number
two, you're throwing away your
chance, no matter how small.
You're throwing away the only
chance you have of the wonderful
vacation.
Well, each of us has to decide
for themselves.
But when I think about this
case, this modified case,
I still want to say choosing
door number two could be a
perfectly rational decision.
It's just not right to say the
only rational decision is
door number one.
Again, if somebody wanted to
take a more modest position and
say, it depends on how great the
vacation would be,
how mild the torture would be,
maybe 1% chances versus a 5%
chance--there's room for debate
about when might the balance
come closer to even so it would
be reasonable to take the
chance.
Yeah, there's room for debate.
But if the chances are small
enough and the person insists
nonetheless, no matter how small
the chances are,
it could never be rational to
pick door number two,
I can only say that doesn't
seem to be the way we would
normally think about making
choices.
And of course,
at this point,
you can see how the argument
exactly carries over to suicide.
If you kill yourself,
you're throwing away forever
any chance of recovery.
And that's important and that's
worth thinking about.
But it's also important to
think about what was the chance
of recovery?
How large, or more to the
point, just how small?
And how badly off will you be
if you don't commit suicide?
You guys are 20,
but of course,
these sorts of choices also
perhaps get faced by people who
are considerably older and now
in the final stages of some
progressive disease.
The doctor's told them,
perhaps they're 70,
that there's no significant
chance of recovery.
Sometimes it happens,
but no more than 1 in 100 or 1
in 1,000.
But if you continue alive,
you will be in,
well, perhaps great pain,
perhaps unable to do the
various things that give your
life meaning and value.
Could it be true that it would
never be rational,
provided that you're thinking
clearly,
never rational to say,
look, the chances of something
negative are so overwhelmingly
great,
that even though deciding for
death throws away whatever small
chance I've got of recovery,
the chance of recovery is so
small that on balance,
it's reasonable to throw that
chance away and avoid the
overwhelmingly likely
possibility that I'll continue
in my current state with a life
not worth living?
It seems that if you're
thinking clearly,
there could be cases in
which suicide would be a
rational choice.
But that still leaves us with
the question,
well, maybe that's where all
the work needs to be done.
What about this point about
thinking clearly?
Even if we grant,
for the sake of argument,
that there could be cases in
which the person's life is so
bad that they actually are
better off dead and they stay
that way,
even if we grant that,
if only somebody were thinking
clearly, they would see that
that was so likely to be the
case,
that suicide would be a
rational or reasonable choice,
still isn't it plausible to
think that in real life,
people can't think clearly
about their situation when
they're in situations like that?
Look, it's one thing for us to
be sitting here in this
classroom, where I certainly
hope that none of you are in
this kind of situation.
It's easy for us to be sitting
here thinking clearly about it
and recognize the philosophical
possibility of thinking clearly
about a case and realizing that
it was a rational decision to
end it,
end your life.
But people who are actually in
those situations in point of
fact are not able to think
clearly.
Because just think about it.
What would have to be true of
you for your life to be so bad
that suicide might be a rational
choice, that you'd be better off
dead?
Odds are you've got to be in
some, indeed more than just
some, you've got to be in a
great deal of pain.
Probably a great deal of
physical pain.
Beyond that,
you probably also need to be
incapacitated in a certain large
number of ways,
so that perhaps you're
bedridden, can't enjoy
discussions with your family,
can't read poetry,
or watch television,
or whatever it is.
A life watching television may
not be as fantastic as the life
that you all are able to have,
but it might still be better
than nothing.
To imagine a life so bad,
it's going to have to have so
much physical disability that
the amount of emotional distress
is going to have to be so
overwhelming,
how could anybody think clearly
in a situation like that?
And then, the argument might
go, if you can't think clearly,
you can't rationally decide to
trust the judgment you
might make that you're in a
situation where suicide is a
reasonable choice.
You might make the judgment,
but if we ask ourselves,
should you trust your opinion?
the odds are,
so the argument goes,
no, you shouldn't trust your
opinion, precisely because
anybody for whom it would be
true would have to be so
emotionally distressed that
they're not able to think
clearly.
If they're not able to think
clearly, they can't have a
judgment that's trustworthy.
If the judgment's not
trustworthy, you shouldn't trust
it.
And so, suicide could never
turn out to be a rational
opinion after all.
Well, that's an interesting
argument.
It think it's an argument more
worth taking seriously than some
of the other ones,
some of the early objections
we've had against suicide.
But even here,
I'm not convinced.
Let's again try to think of a
case not quite like suicide and
ask ourselves,
can't there be cases where
despite the fact that your
thinking is clouded,
it's still reasonable to trust
the decisions that you make
within your clouded thinking?
Suppose you've got some disease
that causes you a great deal of
incapacity and a great deal of
pain.
But as it happens,
there's a cure,
or at least there's a surgical
procedure that can be done,
and the surgical procedure is
almost always successful.
So, what are the choices?
Choice number one,
continue in your current state.
You've got some horrible,
painful disease and it won't
get better unless you have the
surgery.
If you do have the surgery,
it's very, very likely that it
will get better,
99 cases out of 100 the surgery
works,
or 99.9 cases out of 100 the
surgery works,
or 99.99 cases out of 100 the
surgery works.
Of course, like all surgery,
there are risks.
Sometimes you put the person
under anesthesia and they don't
wake up.
It doesn't happen very often,
1 in 1,000,1 in 10,000,1 in
100,000, whatever it is.
There's some chance the surgery
won't work and you'll die on the
operating table.
But it's a very,
very small chance,
overwhelmingly likely the
surgery will succeed.
And if it does succeed,
you'll be recovered.
That's option number one.
Option number two,
you continue in your current
state, incapacitated,
unable to lead a valuable life,
suffering, full of pain.
Well, that's overwhelmingly
likely.
1 in 1,000 cases there's some
sort of natural cure,
maybe 1 in 10,000 cases there's
a natural cure.
But in 999 out of 1,000 cases
or 9,999 out of 10,000 cases,
the disease just continues
until, until you die some years
down the road.
There's your choice.
Should you have the surgery or
not?
Well, I suppose what we think
is, of course you should
have the surgery.
You'd be a fool not to have the
surgery.
It's overwhelmingly likely
going to cure you.
But now we worry.
Wait a minute.
Can you trust that judgment?
After all, the condition you
are in is so stressful,
so painful, that you are
obviously very emotionally
worked up.
And any judgment that you make
that it's a reasonable decision
to have this surgery is a
judgment you're making while
under the cloud of emotional
distress.
How could you possibly trust
that judgment?
And so you shouldn't trust the
judgment, the argument goes.
And so you must never agree to
the surgery in this situation.
But that can't be right.
Surely we agree that it
could be reasonable to
trust your judgment in this
situation.
Now, to be sure,
the fact that you are in all of
this pain should make you pause,
should make you hesitate,
should make you think twice,
and then think again,
before deciding what to do.
But still, if somebody says,
since you're so worked up,
it could never be
rational to decide to have the
surgery,
that just seems to be going too
far.
It doesn't make sense.
You've got to make some kind of
decision.
Deciding not to have the
surgery is still making a kind
of decision.
And either decision then is a
judgment that you're going to be
making while worked up,
while stressed,
while under the cloud of pain
and suffering.
So think twice.
Think a third time.
Get the opinions of others,
perhaps.
But still, if somebody says it
could never be rational
to decide to have the surgery
and then act on that decision,
they're just wrong.
Well, now let's come back to
the suicide case.
Same kinds of odds,
just reversed.
If you don't decide to commit
suicide, we are imagining that
it's overwhelmingly likely
you'll continue in suffering.
Some slight chance that you'll
recover, but overwhelmingly
likely you'll continue in
suffering.
Whereas, if you do kill
yourself, it's overwhelmingly
likely and perhaps even
guaranteed, your suffering will
come to an end.
The only chance that it won't
is if you think there's some
chance of an afterlife.
Well, should we be swayed by
the argument at this point that
since you are suffering,
your judgment is cloudy and so
you should not trust your
judgment?
Well, that can't be a good
argument.
If it wasn't a good argument in
the surgery case,
I can't see how it could
suddenly become a good argument
in the suicide case.
What does seem right is,
precisely because you're
working and deciding under the
cloud of emotional stress and
pain,
that you should think twice,
and think a third time,
and perhaps think yet again.
You should not make this
decision in haste.
You should discuss it with your
doctors.
loved ones.
But if somebody says you could
never reasonably trust the
judgment that you make while in
these circumstances,
I can only say that doesn't
seem like a sound piece of
advice.
That claim doesn't seem right
to me.
I conclude, therefore,
that as long as we're focused
on the question of the
rationality of suicide,
ethics aside,
the rationality of suicide
under certain circumstances,
suicide could be rationally
justified.
You could have a life that is
worse than nothing.
You could have good reason to
believe you were in that
situation.
You could either be thinking
clearly about your situation,
or even if your judgment is
clouded and difficult,
you could still find the odds
sufficiently great that it was
reasonable to eventually trust
your judgment.
The rationality of suicide,
I think, is secured.
But for all that of course,
it could still be
immoral.
There could be actions that are
rationally legitimate,
but for all that,
morally illegitimate.
As I mentioned previously,
there's a big debate in
philosophy as to whether or not
these two things can really come
apart or not.
Arguably, reason actually
requires you to obey morality,
and so even if something's in
your self-interest,
perhaps it's not rational to do
it, if it's immoral.
Interesting question.
Let's just bracket that
question and just focus directly
on the question now of morality.
What should we say about the
morality of suicide?
Rationality aside,
what should we say about the
morality of suicide?
Well, to really do justice to
this question,
of course, we would need to
have an entire theory of
morality laid down,
and unsurprisingly,
I don't have time to do that
for us, an entire class on
introduction to ethics where we
try to lay down a basic
fundamental theory about
morality.
All we've got left is a couple
of minutes today and then one
more lecture.
So instead, what I want to do
is first mention some quick and
dirty arguments that have a kind
of moral tinge to them.
And then turn to some somewhat
more systematic arguments where
I'll quickly put in place some
basic elements of a plausible
moral theory.
We won't have time to explore
them in detail,
but at least we'll get a shape
of a basic moral theory and see
what it might say about suicide.
So, systematic a little bit
later, first some quick and
dirty arguments.
Whether we should call it a
moral argument,
the first one,
or not, I'm not quite certain.
But it's certainly an argument
that gets stated all the time in
this area.
When we think about the
legitimacy of suicide,
it's common enough to have the
reaction, suicide is
illegitimate because it's
thwarting God's will.
Maybe this isn't so much a
moral argument as a theological
argument.
And for the most part,
of course, as you know in this
class, I've avoided at least
some theological questions.
Obviously, questions about the
existence of a soul is itself a
theological argument.
But I've tried to discuss them
as far as possible without
bringing in questions about God,
God's existence and God's will.
But the topic's almost
unavoidable when we think about
suicide, given the prevalence of
the thought,
it's God's will that we stay
alive and so it's going against
God's will to kill ourselves.
Well, I think the best response
to this argument was given by
David Hume some several
centuries ago,
two and a half centuries ago,
where Hume says,
look, if all we've got to go on
is just the idea of a Creator
who has built us and given us
life,
we can't infer that suicide is
against God's will.
At least, if you've found that
thought a compelling one,
then why wouldn't you also find
it compelling to say it goes
against God's will when you
save somebody's life?
This is a point that's close to
one I've raised before.
You're walking along Chapel
Street and the person you're
talking to, you see,
is about to be hit by a car.
So you push them out of the way.
Previously, when we talked
about this question,
the question was whether or not
they should be grateful to you.
Now the question is whether or
not they should complain,
"How dare you do that!
You've thwarted God's will.
It was God's will that I be hit
by that truck."
So, when we're about to save
somebody's life,
should we decide not to do that
on the grounds that it must be
God's will that they're going to
die?
If you're a doctor and
somebody's in cardiac arrest and
you could now perform CPR,
or whatever it is,
in order to get their heart
going again, should we say as a
doctor,
"Oh no, I must not do that.
It's God's will that they die.
If I try to save their life,
I'm thwarting God's will."
Well, nobody says that.
But then, why is the argument
any better in the case of
suicide?
We could of course imagine,
when you've saved your friend's
life and he says,
"Oh, you thwarted God's will,"
what you might come back and say
is, "Oh, no, no.
You see, it was God's will that
I save your life.
And so it was God's will that
you be in the situation where
the truck was going to hit you
unless I saved you.
But it was also God's will that
I save your life."
And maybe the doctor should say
something similar.
Not an implausible thing to say.
But given that that's not an
implausible thing to say,
why not say the same thing
about suicide?
It was God's will that I be in
this situation,
and then God's will that I kill
myself.
Absent any special instruction
manual from God,
the God's will argument cuts
both ways, which is to say it
doesn't give us any guidance.
We don't know whether it's
God's will that we act,
or God's will that we don't
act, absent an instruction
manual from God.
So, we can't conclude that
suicide is obviously wrong,
because it violates God's will.
Well, unless you've got an
instruction manual.
You might think,
for example,
that the Bible tells us not to
commit suicide.
And since the Bible is God's
word, we must do whatever the
Bible tells us.
That's a kind of argument that
I'm perfectly prepared to engage
in.
Although, of course,
there's a lot of assumptions
behind that argument that we
would need to really examine.
Is there a God?--Well,
obviously we needed that
weighing in for the God's will
argument.--Has God expressed his
will in a book?
If so, what book is it?
Do we have moral reason to obey
God?
Also relevant for the God's
will argument.
And of course,
if we do think we have an
obligation to obey this
instruction manual,
are we really prepared to obey
this instruction manual?
Even if there's a sentence in
this instruction manual that
says don't commit suicide,
a lot of other things the
instruction manual also says
that most of us are not inclined
to do.
The instruction manual says not
to eat pork.
Well, how many of you are not
willing to eat pork?
The instruction manual tells
you not to mix various kinds of
material together in a single
item of clothing.
How many of you think that
that's unacceptable?
The instruction manual tells
you that if a teenager is rude
to their parents,
they should be stoned to death.
How many of you think that
that's a moral requirement?
If you're going to pick and
choose which bits of the
instruction manual you actually
think are morally relevant,
then you can't come to me and
say, "Oh, suicide is wrong
because the instruction manual
says so."
You're not really using the
instruction manual to give you
moral guidance.
You're starting with your moral
beliefs and then picking and
choosing which bits of the
instruction manual you want to
accept.
Well, that's a big question.
That's a big topic.
And so having just touched on
it, I'm going to have to put it
aside.
Instruction manual aside,
at the very least,
we might say,
appeal to God's will can't help
us to decide whether or not
suicide is legitimate or not.
But there's a different quick
and dirty argument.
Also it can be run in a
theological form,
but it need not be run that
way.
And that has to do with
gratitude.
We've been given life and
life's pretty amazing.
And so we have an obligation,
a debt of gratitude to keep the
gift.
Now look, gratitude is not one
of the moral virtues that gets a
lot of discussion nowadays.
It's fallen on rather hard
times.
But I see no reason to dismiss
it.
It does seem to me there is
such a thing as a debt of
gratitude.
If someone does you a favor,
you owe them something.
You owe them a debt of
gratitude.
And so the argument might then
go, look, either God gave us
life, or nature gave us life,
or our parents gave us life.
Whatever it was,
we owe a debt of gratitude for
this wonderful gift.
And as such,
how do you repay the debt?
You repay the debt by
keeping the gift.
If you kill yourself,
you're rejecting the gift.
That's being ungrateful,
and ingratitude is immoral.
It's wrong.
And that's why suicide is wrong.
That's the second quick and
dirty argument.
Perhaps it won't surprise you
that I don't find this second
argument persuasive either.
Not because I'm skeptical about
debts of gratitude,
but I want us to pay attention
to what exactly obligations of
gratitude require us to do.
In particular,
it's important to bear in mind
that you owe the person who
gives you a gift something only
when what he's giving you,
or she's giving you,
is a gift.
Imagine that somebody,
I'll call him The Bully,
gives you a pie and says,
"Eat it."
But it's not an apple pie.
It's not a cherry pie.
It's some gross,
disgusting, slime pie,
some rotting slime pie,
and he cuts out a big piece and
he says, "Eat it."
Do you owe this person,
as a debt of gratitude,
out of gratitude,
do you owe him the obligation
to eat the pie and continue
eating the pie?
That would seem like a rather
odd thing to claim.
This guy is indeed,
as I've named him,
just a bully.
Now, of course,
typical bullies,
at least in the comic book
cases, bullies are big and
strong.
The bully might be able to say
the following thing to you.
"You eat this pie or I will
beat you up.
I'll beat the crap out of you."
And look, I'm not a very strong
guy.
He might well be able to do it,
and I might not,
I might well know he is going
to do it.
And so, it might be
prudent for me to eat the
slime pie, disgusting,
appalling as it may be.
It might be better to have a
couple of slices of slime pie
than to be beaten up to a pulp.
But there's no moral obligation
here.
There's no moral requirement to
eat the pie.
Well, if God takes on the role
of bully and says,
"Eat the pie or I'll send you
to hell," maybe it would be
prudent of you to do what he
says.
And if God takes on the role of
bully and says,
"Even though your life has
become so horrible that you'd be
better off dead,
I insist that you keep living
or I'll send you to hell if you
kill yourself,"
maybe it's prudent of you not
to kill yourself.
But there's no moral
requirement here.
God's just a bully on this
story.
Now, that's not to say that I
think God is a bully.
If you believe,
plausibly enough,
God is good,
then God's not going to want
you to continue eating the pie
once it's spoiled.
He gives you an apple pie.
He says, "Eat it.
It's good for you.
You'll like it."
Out of gratitude, you eat it.
But then God,
not being a bully,
says, "If the pie ever spoils,
you can stop eating."
Why in the world would he
insist that we continue to eat a
spoiled pie if He's not a bully?
So, I can't see how any
argument from gratitude is going
to get off the ground.
If there's something immoral
about suicide,
we're not going to get the
immorality through these quick
and dirty arguments.
We're going to have to get it
from some more systematic appeal
to moral theory.
And that's what we'll turn to
next time.